she's doing great work thanks denise
that is a great way to use your talent
ted is uh standing by his talent one of
them is bringing you the weather each
and every day
thank you and i'm loving what we have
ahead for this weekend
that was an interesting bow is it was it
a double i didn't know
how to respond to that well take take
the compliment buddy
you want me to buy you dinner don't you
tonight that's it that's exactly
the way to my heart is compliments thank
you so much clear skies outside right
now this is our camera
we have so many tower cams okay that
just inundate the valley so we can track
storms
this one up on black mountain on our
tower you can see the las vegas strip
mainly clear skies the high today 91
degrees
now yesterday we're at 98. all right so
we cooled things off just a little bit
still remains warm still remains above
average that average temperature is 86
typically this time of the year the
record on this date
102 set back in 1989. currently outside
and again we'll switch up our
neighborhoods here so nobody's left out
sky canyon centennial hills are both at
89 spring valley 87
91 north las vegas still in the low 90s
for sunrise manor and
whitney ranch at 91 includes also
whitney ranch
and i should say a green valley 91 for
henderson
88 from mountains edge southern
highlands you're also at 88 along with
anthem
this also includes rhodes ranch and in
sprata too got a lot of
eight news now viewers out there too 88
for prep 89 boulder city
99 degrees still for death valley not
quite 100 degrees right now not quite
the century mark
as far as the southwest radar goes get
this there's a front okay we've been
watching that front typically you'll get
showers and storms ahead of that front
because it lifts all that up and allows
those to develop
we're seeing those showers move into
salt lake but if you look very closely
at the tail end of this front here we
actually have some isolated showers and
thunderstorms just east of goldfield
this is in
nye county now moving through we don't
think we can get any here we're going to
stay on the dry side
but we will get those elevated winds as
that front slides through this is all
from the southwest so tonight
still breezy winds for us and then those
winds will
also be around for tomorrow too here's
your weekend forecast 88 degrees for
saturday we're going to match that
number just in time for mom's day too
warm and windy 30 miles per hour gusts
and then mother's day will keep around
some breezes also for
mom's day too tonight 67 degrees
overnight breezy and mild tomorrow your
high
88 like we talked about windy and cooler
and
those numbers for tomorrow will be close
to the high 80s close to 90s i should
say some of you will touch in those 90s
like sunrise manor green valley possibly
nellis
86 for centennial hills outside the
valley 85 for prim
and state line 97 for lofland eight on
the eight your eight day forecast
next week look at that we'll be in those
high 80s for a little while back to the
90s again and then
cooling off a little for uh the weekend
next week that's your most accurate
forecast brian
ted when john saw the 88 and sunny he
went like this
yes and what he was doing he was
applauding without distracting you with
sound
thank you john john will go from
applauding to reporting on a jam-packed